ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
43rd president of the united states
thank you
thank you very much laura and i are
honored to be with you
man vice president
vice president cheney
governor wolf secretary holland and
distinguished guests
20 years ago
we all found in different ways
in different places
but all at the same moment
that our lives would be changed forever
the world was loud with carnage
and silence
and then quiet with missing voices
that would never be heard again
these lives remain precious to our
country
and infinitely precious to many of you
today we remember your loss
we share your sorrow
and we honor the men and women that you
have loved for so long and so well
for those too young to recall that clear
september day
it is hard to describe the mix of
feelings we experienced
there was horror
there was horror at the scale of
destruction
and awe at the bravery and kindness that
rose to meet it
there was shock at the audacity audacity
of evil
and gratitude for the heroism and
decency that opposed it
and the sacrifice of the first
responders
in the mutual aid of strangers
in the solidarity of grief and grace
the actions of an enemy revealed the
spirit of a people
and we were proud of our wounded nation
in these memories the passengers and
crew of flight 93
must always have an honor in place
here the intended targets
became the instruments of rescue
and many who are now alive owe a vast
unconscious death
to the defiance display
in the skies above this field
it would be a mistake to idolize the
experience of those terrible events
all that many people could initially see
was the brute randomness of death
all that many could feel was unearned
suffering
all that many could hear
was god's terrible silence
there are many who still struggle
with the lonely pain that cuts deep
within
in those faithful hours
we learned other lessons as well
we saw that americans were vulnerable
but not fragile
that they possess a core of strength
that survives the worst that life can
bring
we learned that bravery is more common
than we imagined
merging with sudden splendor
in the face of death
we vividly felt how hour with our loved
ones
was a temporary and holy gift
and we found that even the longest days
ended
many of us have tried to make spiritual
sense of these events
there is no simple explanation for the
mix of providence and human will
that sets the direction of our lives
but comfort can come from a different
sort of knowledge
after wandering long and lost in the
dark
many have found they were actually
walking
step by step toward grace
as a nation our adjustments had been
profound
many americans struggled to understand
why an enemy would hate us with such
zeal
the security measures incorporated into
our lives
are both sources of comfort
and reminders of our vulnerability
and we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across borders
but from violence that gathers within
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but in their disdain for pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
after 9 11
millions of brave americans stepped
forward and volunteered to serve in the
armed forces
the military measures taken over the
last 20 years to pursue dangers at their
source
have left to debate
but one thing is certain
we own assurance to all who have fought
our nation's most recent battles
let me speak directly to veterans and
people in uniform
the cause you pursued at the call of
duty is the noblest america has to offer
you have shielded your fellow citizens
from danger
you have defended the beliefs of your
country
and advanced the rights of the
downtrodden
you have been the face of hope
and mercy in dark places
you have been a force for good in the
world
nothing that has followed
nothing
can tarnish your honor
or diminish your accomplishments
to you and to the honored dead
our country is forever grateful
in the weeks and months following the 9
11 attacks i was proud to lead an
amazing resilient united people
when it comes to the unity of america
those days seem distant from our own
malign force seems at work in our common
life
that turns every disagreement into an
argument
and every argument into a clash of
cultures
so much of our politics has become a
naked appeal to anger fear and
resentment
that leaves us worried about our nation
and our future together
i come without explanations or solutions
i can only tell you what i've seen
on america's day of trial and grief
i saw millions of people instinctively
grab for a neighbor's hand
and rally to the cause of one another
that is the america i know
at a time when religious bigotry might
have flowed freely
i saw americans reject prejudice
and embrace people of muslim faith
that is the nation i know
at a time when nativism could have
stirred hatred and violence against
people perceived as outsiders
i saw america's reaffirm their welcome
to immigrants and refugees
that is the nation i know
at a time when some viewed the rising
generation as individualistic and
decadent
i saw young people embrace an ethic of
service and rise to selfless action
that is the nation i know
this is not mere nostalgia
it is the truest version of ourselves
it is what we have been
and what we can be again
20 years ago terrorists chose a random
group of americans on a routine flight
to be collateral damage in a spectacular
act of terror
the 33 passengers and seven crew of
flight 93
could have been any group of citizens
selected by faith
in a sense
they stood in for us
the terrorists who discovered that a
random group of americans is an
exceptional group of people
facing an impossible circumstance
they comforted their loved ones by phone
braced each other for action
and defeated the designs of evil
these americans were brave strong and
united in ways that shocked the
terrorists
but should not surprise any of us
this is the nation we know
and whenever we need hope and
inspiration
we can look to the skies
[Applause]
you